every now and then when the when the
bombs stop going off and all the
headlines and the smearing and all that
stuff going off I think about my family
and I think about Kim
and I'll think about how you know King
Koopa has her in the castle right now
and just on uh Mario Brothers you know
how it is let's go for the princess and
you get to this level and it's like
I'm like I sung the song wrong right and
then they take the princess again
which one are you Mario yeah
what's your uh favorite thing the thing
you love the most about Kim
from a Mario perspective and the
princess
looking back
was there a moment she's definitely my
favorite of all time yeah was there a
moment that
you know like that catches you off guard
and you say I love this human being
yeah I mean
it's just the the DNA is like she's a
mix of Rob and Chris
can you explain
I mean that's like
a really high pool right there
those are like two geniuses
so okay so like the entire history of uh
evolution of the human species created
this DNA that created this being there's
a life there there's a set of memories
in the history that brought you together
and you're like damn I like this DNA
yeah and so certain people have just
like hi Liana Ivanka Trump has high DNA
you know it's like how's your DNA
pretty good uh I I think we've seen that
it's been proven I mean but look at my
look at my mom and look at my dad you
know me and my dad have a water
purification Center in the Dr
uh right now and my dad is the original
Steve Jobs and he was blocked by people
around him and people were using him and
taking advantage and you know not
believing in his vision he's my dad's
the educated version of yay